among the people killed was a 15 year
old girl on a day out with her family
Leila and nandus just celebrated her
quinceanera in May
her brother was shot but survived a
hundred hundreds attended vigil in
Odessa last night to remember
all of the victims media via rallies
their media how was the community
responding to this
well good morning right now Odessa is
saying that they are strong and they are
determined to get through this as a
community one of the ways that they are
doing that is by leaving messages of
love and support here on the sidewalk at
UT permian basin one reads united we
stand another hate is not welcome here
you know one of the youngest survivors
is a 17 month old baby her mother said
she had no idea where the bullets were
coming from when her baby girl was hit
in the backseat of their car
Kelby Davis says her 17 month old
daughter is home after being caught in
the crossfire while in her car seat
doctors are set to remove shrapnel from
her chest after she was shot in the
tongue and lip knocking out her front
teeth within seconds I looked at
Anderson and she was just covered in
blood so much boy I mean you couldn't
even see her face
fifteen-year-old Leila Ananda celebrated
her quinceanera less than four months
ago she was shot and killed at a local
car dealership where her brother who was
wounded just bought a truck her
classmates at Odessa high school say she
was always smiling it is hard for
everybody who was close to her a truck
driver from Austin is hospitalized after
bullets ripped through his wrist arm and
chest he would just run home I just hear
this Bam Bam m3 and and it was loud
Shawna Saxton says she was driving with
her husband and baby grandson when the
shooter pulled up alongside her I saw a
very large gun come up out of the car
and what are you thinking I said what I
was thinking there's a gun I freaked out
you're still shaking I am it was it's
really hard when someone points a very
large good at you and you relive it in
your mind and you see his face and he
hated he was full of rage and something
else I don't even know what Shawna was
able to maneuver through traffic and
finally get away from the gunman before
she says he reloaded that gun that
youngest victim baby Anderson she's
doing very well she's actually back at
home she was playing with her twin
brother last night and she's expected to
make a full recovery
Tony well that's good news Moran thank
you very much